get in by perck centering feed but Marilla
couldn't Tee It Up Ryan Tado back the other
way for Chicago Let's It Go Johansson's in the
game makes the first big stop of the hockey
game without Andre vasileski in the net is that
you theonis Johansson who's played most of the
games and you know he's just not vasileski so
you can't give him high danger chances all the
time well St Louis the other night Johansson
got ripped apart late in the game as Tampa
got more he's sure of what he wants and what
he needs but he he also knows that this is a
building block step by step Hegel tried to make
a play he's still on it now able to keep in the
zone tight quarters for Tampa kucherov got it
through Hegel skating backwards makes the pass
rocket shot there from danan missed the mark
kept in by radish asaman in for Tampa takes
the puck away asaman Along the wall swings
it back for cherick that shot was stopped
by moric not sure I saw that coming Jano pokes
a little deeper that's off the outside of the
pipe by asot put some juice in this building if
they can find a way to score reel will play the
bumper on his power play here's Bernard
cent in front and he got the stick down
Hegel On It Centers through with speed
Celli shorthanded big save Peter moric
to keep it scoreless maybe what we
needed was a Blackhawk Power Play
Chances at both ends there Seth Jones will leave
it Berard through center with speed got
it through here's kurashev tried to go
through the dots for reel Blackhawks haven't
been able to really set things up Cory Perry
will go net front presence cor chinsky
swings it off looking for the re after
the score it's Lucas reel his first goal
of the season comes on the power play and
it's one- nothing Chicago Lucas REO is in
the bumper position the middle of the ice
on the Blackhawks power play no goals on the
season they want him to be more involved they
need him to be more involved on defensively so
they figure if they get him in the middle he's
going to have more touches on the puck it's a
heads up play from KF this is a shot pass the
deflection shot blocked out to Defence
good job there by cherik racing in COV
tried to Center in front braen Point whacking
at it can't beat morazzi final minute of play
side of the net here's Point it'll go back to
the point perix lets it go shot is stopped by
morazzi with crazy traffic in front of the net
morazzi does a real nice job and then Kaiser
is going to man Cory Perry's had a nice night
too was here's a chance here's mut breaking in
he shoots and moric the save mck tried to go
short side and another glove save morazzi will
gobble that one up his ground and in the first
period Peter morazzi stopped Brandon Hegel on
a Breakaway here he stops Tyler M on one he's on
it now he'll go back to the point there there's
COV Po in the bumper Paul net front
presence headman lets it Go shot
the score Bren point on the power play
and the lightning have tied the game at
one this looks a lot like Lucas reel's goal
in the first period for Chicago Tamp against
the puck watch this nice work on the wall
here by Nick Paul as he's going to have to
dig it off the wall and make a nice little
pass back to coov two passes later it's Bren
points deflection off the headman shot man these
three guys have been in a lot of goals together
coocher off to headman to point moraza can't
catch up to it through that Nick Paul scream
what I liked was Paul started the play here in
the corner and then he gets to the front help
the traffic in front of moric hey it looks
like there's some conversation going on in
that Chicago bench if if that's the play they're
looking at the question will be whether points
is in control of the puck as the puck hits his
stick you anybody Chicago is deter was a good
goal Chicago assess a play of game that's minor
knocked down out of midair by Nick Felino and
some pressure ant whistle pressuring headman
there and whistle stays on it to the front of
the net that shot blocked out the defense here's
sergachev catches glass chernick will roll up for
it goes off the stick there of Phillips lightning
is set up pretty well here cach shot score and it
goes through a maze of players and in and for
the first time tonight the Tampa Bay Lightning
have the lead two to one goal yet this year and
sergachev starts this play with a long shot the
the lightning retrieve it they win the the puck
around the boards they win it back behind the
net as stamp Coast keeps this Play Alive a nice
little touch pass to point and there's the tra
Dickinson comes over to help out work free the
headman COV tried the one timer Chicago looks to
counter and break Cory Perry he's got some help
try to swing it across in front side of the net
tick tac toe and it's Cory Perry who finishes off
a brilliant Chicago setup and the Blackhawks have
tied the game at two fourth starts on a turnover
inside the Tampa offensive line as kucherov turns
it over now it's a two-on one headman back
back pressure coming to the middle of the ice
and Dickinson is going to deflect this Puck over
towards Cory Perry who's now standing a foot and
a half from the net nice little touch pass and
there's no chance for Johansson there as Kaiser
came over to free him from the puck a lightning
Jump On It here's Braden point with a step on
his backand and sto by moric in the rebound as
well and Bard spending a lot of energy in the
shift in his own end Ray it's a critical piece
chernack swings it across for headman goes back
chernack to traffic morz never saw and the bounce
off the end boards and it's in Victor hman has put
Tampa Bay on top back on top with 807 to play
able to keep it a alive but the play continues
on and Chicago never gets back into position and
as hman started the play went down low he comes
in and grabs that loose Puck off that's a great
hockey expression they don't call it minus it's
dash dash for here's point with a step what else
did do cuts in another big stop for morazzi and
no rebound it's a crisp rink wide pass from coov
to point point gets around the back again it just
seems like Tampa is trailing by a goal not the
other way around here's a chance kurashev in and a
save by Johansson Perry had tied the game earlier
in the period for Hond put Tampa on top shoot in
and shot right back out Hegel with an empty net
and he'll flip it top of the net for the goal
and the Clincher for the Tampa Bay Lightning
put this one away P's going to try and create
some action in the offensive zone by himself as
he chips it in but sergachev is right there and
he just flips it high out to Center I and hang on
headman's on it there be a game-winning goal for
Victor Hond tie it up back behind the cage and the
horn sounds ending the hockey game here tonight